Hello everyone, welcome to Next Level
Commander and today we're ranking the
top 10 precon phase commanders of all
time and number one is not a track set.
Do you remember when you picked your
first precon deck? For many of us it was
a big deal. You can mess this one up.
The commander you choose will determine
whether next month's lunch money goes
towards blue instance or black zombies.
It's a relationship, a commitment to
that face commander and it was your
identity at the magic table. Later, as
we dived into the expert expansions, we
start building more decks. Maybe we take
on an all colors challenge. We explore
strategies, refine our tastes, and chase
the wildest synergies. But no matter how
far we branch out, the first phase
commander always holds a special place
in our hearts. It's more than just the
first deck. It's how we learn to
navigate the table, where we found our
first victories, and how we begin
shaping who we are as players. And today
we will go back to where that journey
began for many. Ranking the 10 best face
commanders. And by best, we're not
talking about power or popularity. We're
looking for designs that are clever and
timeless. Number 10 brings us Brea. And
I'll be honest, there's definitely some
personal bias here. Brea has become one
of my favorite commander decks because
of how well she enables aggro. And not
just any aggro, white weeny aggro. This
is something that was nearly impossible
in commander before. White weenie, the
strategy of pushing through honest,
hardworking damage with reasonably
sized, lowcost creatures, has always
struggled in this format. It doesn't
have the reach of red, nor the scaling
of green. And for a long time, it was
more or less an afterthought in
commander. Just ask the players who
tried building Isamaru decks in the
early days. Then Brea came along and
suddenly creatures like adorned pouncer,
benevolent bodyguard, and even this
horseman thing found a place in
commander. Brina offers both reach and
gas, allowing you to swarm the board
early with these lowcost creatures,
sometimes irresponsibly so long as you
keep Brea protected. And the political
element can also be explored with cards
like combat calligrapher and dualist
heritage. In terms of longevity and in
terms of being future proof, well, every
time white or black gets some pushed low
to the ground creatures, Brina eats. For
as long as White Weenies continues to
thrive in 60 card magic, Brina will be
their gateway into commander. So, all
things considered, I believe that Brina
deserves a shout in the top 10. Next up
at number nine, Enya Falcon Wrath. Now,
this one might be a bit controversial. I
mean, it's ranked 354th on EDH with only
5,000 decks, but at this point, you're 3
minutes into the video, maybe. So, I got
my viewer retention. Okay, just kidding.
Don't leave. Hear me out. Enya is simple
and elegant in its design and it won't
be outdated for a long time. It isn't
broken by any means, but it enables
quite a few strategies. Madness, of
course, but reanimator is a really fun
one. Before Anna, Reanimator did not
work in commander. Now, I'm not talking
about recursion. I'm talking about
reanimator as in you dump a fatty into
the graveyard and bring it out with
cards like Reanimate and Animate Dead in
the early turns of the game, preferably,
and take over your opponents before they
could respond. The problem with
reanimator in commander is that you have
to get a discard spell, reanimation
spell, and a fatty all in very early
stages of the game to make it work.
That's just a lot of effort for not so
much
payoff. Well, this is still true, but
Enya makes the setup part a lot easier
and more consistent. You are guaranteed
a looter from the command zone, which
will give you two activations by turn
four. when your opponents are still
dropping their explosive vegetations and
solemn similacrims you have in Ulumak
and sure it's still not going to take
over the game but Enya will keep the
engine running feeding you backup
threats and maybe eventually a living
death the strategies that Enya enables
strikes a nice balance between power and
novelty and that's why I have her in the
top 10 number eight Zedru the
greathearted the first commander set had
a lot of gems a lot it makes sense
because they had over 20 years of design
space and Zedru filled a massive one
giving Giving your opponent's gifts that
blow up in their face will never not be
funny to newer players. And more
experienced players will always enjoy
exploring the synergies and rules
interactions involved. And to this day,
we are getting cards for this theme, but
never a commander better than Zu. What's
preventing Zedru from ranking higher is
the design is a bit conservative in my
opinion for a strategy that puts you
through hoops after hoops. It costs
seven mana to cast Zu and make your
first donation and you don't reap the
mediocre benefits until a turn later. I
mean just look at steel kid. But still
to this day 14 years after it release
zedu represents an entire archetype. And
whenever we get a funny donatable
permanent we still think of zedu. And
that is what I mean by timeless. Number
seven we are looking at another Jessica
commander. Zenia valley's voice. A bird
barred from Bloomber that strikes a
balance between power and charm. I mean
it's a stork delivering babies that's
just adorable. Just think about the baby
war hounds, baby sun titans, baby
aldrazi. What's not to love? But at the
same time, Zenia packs a lot of power.
It adds a clever twist to the
traditional creature ETB decks, not only
for doubling the ETB triggers, but also
opens up space for playing creatures
that work with themselves. And on top of
that, bringing tokens into the equation
also opens up the door for populating
strategies. And if all that fails, Zenia
is even capable of pushing through
commander damage. So, Zenia is a
perfectly competent commander for
creature ETB decks, but at the same
time, it opens up so much more
possibility for you to play around with,
and it is open-ended enough that it will
be a commander constantly brought up
whenever a new set releases. And that's
why I have it in the top 10. For number
six, we are staying in the same postal
code, the same profession even, Bellow,
Bard of the Brambles. Artifact and
enchantment decks are common, but Bellow
adds a whole new twist. You'll
understand when you see a double
striking berserker onslaught coming your
way. Traditional artifacts and
especially enchantment decks had always
struggled with closing out games, often
relying on locks, combos, and sometimes
concessions. Bellow embracing the gr
color provides the most direct and no BS
solution. And the deck is so interesting
to build. You see players ditching sky
shroud claims for enroaching dragon
storms. And you see as chariot driving
itself and also you see the one ring
players giving up on that sweet sweet
value just to smack you with the
indestructible ring. Also worth noting
is that Bellow's ability is static and
constant during your turn. So your
enchantments and artifacts will trigger
ETB abilities. I mean, Warstorm Surge
triggering itself is just pure chaotic
and mind-boggling fun, and no one is
safe. Moving on to number five, and I
know there are a few names you've been
waiting for. Whether you like this video
or write an angry comment after clicking
report comes down to the second half.
Although I'm fairly confident about this
number five, Prosper Homebound. talking
about an open-ended commander or what I
like to call crossroads commanders. You
can take dozens of different paths and
Prosper will be sitting at the center
handing out treasure tokens to everyone.
As long as it involves Exile, it
triggers. Now, see if I can even name
them all. Impulse Draw, Cascade,
Discover, Plot, Forell, Madness,
Adventure, Suspend, Rebound, and
Ragavan. Am I missing any? That's
hundreds, if not thousands of cards that
you can just mix and match to build your
unique strategy. A future proof
commander tends to get solid cards every
year. And then there's Prosper, who gets
entirely new mechanics every year. Must
be nice. Number four, I can sense your
mouse closing in on that report button.
Now, if you can't find it, it's hidden
on the top right on the video
description section behind the three
dots. I usually choose hateful or
abusive content or misinformation. But
don't do it just yet because number
four, we have Henzy Toolbox. Tory
creatures will always be the number one
favorite card type for commander
players. And like Zenia, Henzy adds a
special Jundy twist to the inviting
creatures over just to kill them again
and again archetype. Costing just three
mana, he will be online early and also
has a cleverly designed ability that
makes him more and more relevant late
game, even changing the way you play
late games. Sure, you're still playing a
typical Jun Creatures deck, but with
more synergistic card choices. Cards
like Ojer Jasim, Primeval Herald, and G
triplets are ridiculous value with Henzy
on the field. Not to mention that the
haste allows for a more aggressive play
style. You never know when a tree shaker
Chimera is coming down to take your
board away. And all in all, Henzi is one
of the most interesting creature
commanders we've seen in a long while.
And the community seems to agree. Now we
move on to number three, the Moplasm.
Talk about a simple yet timeless design
with infinite possibilities. If Prosper
is a crossroads commander, then the
Mimoplasm is a Roma. mill reanimate ETB
creatures power matters plus encounter
synergies combo voltron ooze tribal this
card alone covers like half of the most
popular archetypes and you can mix and
match to your heart's content and more
importantly is fun and requires some
creativity to build lord of extinction
plus walking ballista death shadow plus
blighted agent and currently I have a
mimoplasm deck it is built as a mill
deck that wins by stealing creatures and
spells from opponent's graveyards and
mopplasm is really the glue that holds
it all together reason the mimoplasm is
So high on my list is the balancing.
This card designed 14 years ago is still
perfectly balanced and costed for what
it does in 2025. After a decade and a
half worth of power creeping, they still
couldn't make anything that mopplasms
better than the mimoplasm. And I suspect
this will be the case for the
foreseeable future. And now number two,
and this is what many of you are waiting
for, Attra Prader's voice. Now, I place
her here a little bit begrudgingly
because in my honest opinion, the design
is not interesting at all. Just keyword
soup and proliferate once a turn. Not
even a tap ability so you can play with
the timings. And when that set of
commander decks came out, I predicted
them all to be duds. Let's just say I'm
glad I wasn't a YouTuber back then. But
what I failed to see is that the genius
here isn't in a Traxxas design, but the
keyword proliferate. It just does
everything and interacts with some of
the most popular card types ever
released like planes walkers and sagas.
Honestly, there probably isn't much I
can say about Attra that you don't
already know, but with 35,000 decks in
just the past 2 years is evidence enough
the popularity and longevity of this
fireexian
angel. And finally, number one, it is a
tribal commander. And no, it is not the
air dragon or Edgar Marov. It is Kalia
of the vast. I know, I know now you're
trying to figure out ways to report the
same video twice, but just close your
eyes and imagine being a Magic player
with a commander deck and for every set,
the most exciting and splashy huge
mythic is going into your deck more
likely than not. This is the life of a
Calia player and it's good. From 2011
till now, Kalia went from dropping huge
game ending bombs once in a while to
doing every attack. And it's not just
that. Kalia makes everyone better Magic
players. In the early days, Kalia had a
reputation of being a flat track bully,
dominating newer play groups, but
folding at the first sign of
interaction. As a new player, at first,
I complained about balance issues. It's
so pushed. But once I moved past that, I
started thinking strategically about how
to handle the threat she posed. Over
time, I learned to respect Kalia's power
while keeping her under control. And it
goes both ways, too. As a Calia player,
you quickly learn not to rely too
heavily on your commander. Success comes
from building backup plans, ramp,
reanimator strategies, or cards that
serve similar roles to Kalia. You also
realize you can't just jam in every cool
angel, demon, and dragon you come
across. The deck requires some balance
and tuning. Kalia's high-risk, high
reward play style makes her one of the
most thrilling commanders to pilot or to
go up against, and it will only get
better. And that's all. Did I miss
anything major? What is in your top 10?
How angry are you at my list? Let me
know and subscribe for future videos.
And one nice thing about being a small
channel is that I can read and reply to
every comment and think about them. So
if you have a video that you want to see
in the future, let me know. And if it's
a viable idea and something that YouTube
doesn't already have 10 videos about, I
will do it. The chance of me doing it is
really, really high. So once again,
thank you and I'll see you